marseille au pied des calanques
ludovic vit ses dernières journées de
marins ordinaire comme élève officier de
la marine marchande
ce que je peux passer à 5 seulement il
termine sa deuxième année de formation
seulement bien en tout 180 pilotes à 34
ans cet ancien infirmier est en pleine
reconversion
c'est un rêve de gosse que de pouvoir
être que pouvoir être en bien et en
faire mon métier
ce qui me plaît c'est ça c'est la mère
qui est jamais là même à laquelle il
faut s'adapter en permanence et et le
bateau le bateau en tant que tel il
passe désormais sa vie à naviguer sur
les eaux de la méditerranée si
dangereuse pour ceux qui la traversent
sur des embarcations de fortune
le déclic c'est des moments où j'étais
en mer et où je me suis dit ça se trouve
à 100 à 200 milles de moi là il ya des
jambes de femmes des enfants qui sont
sur des canettes en plastique là et sans
eau sans rien lui balance c'est pas
possible donc le déclic le déclic il a
été là il va s'embarquer trois semaines
à bord de l'aquarius un bateau qui va se
courir les migrants méditerranée mais
plus le départ approche plus le jeune
marin est angoissé je me suis
questionnée je me questionne encore son
mais sur le capacité à affronter ça mais
c'est surtout est-ce que je vais être à
la hauteur mais est-ce que je vais
pouvoir répondre à ce qu'on attend de
moi
mais en tout cas je vais tout faire pour
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de la france à nantes le
long des quais dernière escapade pour
jean
mais oui ces dernières balades à moto le
départ ce jeune officier de la marine
marchande va s'engager lui aussi comme
bénévole en méditerranée je choisis ma
vie à terre mais mes petits plaisirs que
ce soit la motorola pas vraiment autre
chose c'est sûr c'est pas évident de se
dire dans une semaine je serai à bord et
peut-être que dans huit jours ça je
serai confronté à un sauvetage
la demande est de plus en plus forte
c'est pas c'est pas le stress qui me
pincer plus pas de la nervosité dans le
buffet jeune j'ai hâte de retrouver de
retrouver l'aquarium
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la première fois que
j'embarque pour cette mission
humanitaire
l'année dernière il a déjà passé dix
semaines à se courir des naufragés on se
prépare psychologiquement on sait que ça
va pas être facile c'est plus que des
petits problèmes de la vie quotidienne
on tient de vie entre nos mains et on
les arrache à la mort au regard de
l'allemand dans les yeux quand les
distillats tu l'auras pas pendant six
semaines
jean et ludovic vont vivre une
expérience hors du commun au large des
côtes libyennes
là où les embarcations dérivés font
parfois naufrage leur mission sauver les
migrants qui risquent leur vie pour
rejoindre l'europe donne des frissons la
brenne inculte
on sait pas combien ils sont à
l'intérieur
depuis janvier 2017 plus de 3000
personnes sont mortes en méditerranée
désormais ludovic et les autres
volontaires ne font plus face à des
chiffres mais ô désespoir de ces hommes
de ces femmes et de leurs enfants
beaucoup d'émotion des moments intenses
auxquels ces citoyens ordinaires ne sont
pas préparés ensemble ils vont être
confrontés aux témoignages bouleversants
des migrants on a à l'attention des
sauvetages et à la joie des rescapés
une aventure humaine éprouvante que nous
avons suivi à leurs côtés
[Musique]
l'histoire de ces volontaires commence
ici en italie
jean vient tout juste d'arriver
le départ est prévu dans quelques heures
à la tête de l'équipe des bénévoles
stéphane volontaires permanents depuis
un nom à sion
au total 32 personnes seront à bord pour
cette mission
[Musique]
d'avoir 4 5 mètres carrés on va être
deux fois arrivé à faire des concessions
sur son petit confort sont sommes nous
priver son jardin secret super content
de défaire en france 5
c'est la mission qui commence par face à
la cabine de jean celle de ludovic
je suis petit nouveau tout le monde tout
le monde me rassure je m'aperçois que
c'est tous des marins professionnels qui
ont l'expérience qui du savoir faire qui
est d'autant plus ici danser dans cette
activité ultra spécifique en fait qui
n'existe nulle part ailleurs au monde
quoi de sa du sauvetage de masse comme
ça
l'aquarius quitte enfin catane son port
d'attache on vient de larguer la optique
la sicile on peut voir pouvoir l'etna
ses fumerolles là on va être sur zone
dans quelques heures
c'est la 27e mission de l'aquarius
affrété par l'omg sos méditerranée
depuis deux ans financé à plus de 98%
par des dons chaque jour en mer coûte 11
mille euros à bord juliette prépare sa
petite salle de consultations médicales
pour femmes enceintes
juliette est sage femme pour médecins
sans frontières c'est la première fois
qu'elle va travailler sur un bateau
la première fois qu'elle va se courir
des naufragés je me suis un peu demandé
si c'était pas trop pour moi ça va être
le côté de ce qu'ils ont vécu plutôt
quoi qui va être fit cette chance c'est
ça qui est un peu plus qu'on appréhende
un peu plus
stéphane lui est un habitué c'est sa
neuvième mission sur l'aquarius à bord
ce marin breton dirige l'équipe des
sauveteurs les eaux libyennes
on va aller patrouiller entre 30 et 60
km des côtes libyennes
et donc on va dans ces zones là
puisqu'il y appelait les départs de
migrants
il ya des sauvetages dramatique des
drames simplement à un point comme ça
c'est pas possible de fermer les yeux
depuis plus de dix ans la libye est le
pays par lequel passent les principales
routes migratoires partie des pays
d'afrique de l'est et de l'ouest pour
des raisons politiques ou économiques
les migrants y prennent la mer pour
l'europe jusqu'à 22 km de la côte ce
sont les eaux territoriales libyennes
une zone où les ong n'interviennent pas
c'est au delà de ces zozos qu'ont lieu
les opérations de sauvetage
coordonné par un centre de secours basés
à rome
[Musique]
par beau temps les pasteurs peuvent
mettre chaque jour des dizaines
d'embarcations à la mer impossible de
savoir ce qui attend les volontaires une
fois arrivé sur zone
pire c'est un bateau de 20 mètres avec
700 900 mille personnes ou alors ou
alors des gens dans l'eau
oh
des bateaux qui se dégonfle france et
des bateaux gonflables
[Musique]
je prends mon coeur à la base radar r
l'aqua russe vient d'arriver dans la
zone de patrouille
pas mal de vent aujourd'hui gens
commencent les recherches
je pense que je vais aller sur le pont
supérieur les côtes libyennes sont à une
trentaine de kilomètres vas-y
pour échapper aux gardes-côtes libyens
les passeurs met les embarcations à
l'eau en pleine nuit
c'est au petit matin qu'elle arrive dans
les eaux internationales
des centaines de kilomètres de l'italie
veut on leur a promis le
l'eldorado l'arrivée en italie garantie
malheureusement ce n'est pas vraiment
une terre puisqu'il partir des toutes
petites embarcations qui sont pas faites
pour résister aux vagues
ils partent sans nourriture et sans eau
sans boussole n'ont plus qu'à se laisser
dériver attendent à man
si nous on les trouve pas aux personnes
mais trouvent ils ont du coup mis sur
les tons dans deux minutes jouées les
casques les minutes
rien d'autre apparemment il ya 300
personnes on arrive sur zone le centre
de coordination des secours basé à rome
vient de les alerter
une embarcation est en vue
pour ludovic c'est le moment de faire
face tout ce qu'il a imaginé depuis des
mois se déroule maintenant sous ses yeux
terrifiant
ça me donne des frissons à devoir entrer
la [ __ ] ces personnes-là roi où ça 1,5
de gilet en plus j'en prépare les gilet
de sauvetage
bonsoir le maximum c'est des sacs devra
il nous en faut 15
ja
on sait pas combien ils sont à
l'intérieur sur moi un twindexx
c'est-à-dire un pot à l'intérieur où les
gens sont entassés comme des bagages ans
ok la planète
malgré l'urgence l'opération doit
absolument se dérouler dans le calme la
plupart des migrants ne savent pas nager
et le bateau peut chavirer à tout moment
est ce qu'il ya des gens dans la cale
plein plein
ne vous inquiétez pas le plus important
c'est de ne pas bouger
ok surtout ne bougez pas ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps mais n'ayez pas peur
vous allez tous venir sur notre bateau
stéphane is les naufragés sur le bateau
l'un après l'autre
le sauvetage va durer cinq heures
on a ces hommes et dames en hockey feu
vert
hommes femmes enceintes enfants pour la
plupart ils viennent d'erythrée ils ont
dérivé pendant plus de 12 heures depuis
la libye perdue en pleine mer
on a le bébé ok ok
une femme enceinte
[Musique]
l'imam est libre
sans parti sans eau il semblerait donc
seulement on a en arrive-t-on à g le
sauvetage terminé il reste une dernière
mission pour stéphane vérifier qu'aucune
personne ne soient mortes au fond de la
cale dans cette soute
l'air est irrespirable à cause des
vapeurs d'essence certains migrants
s'évanouissent et se noie dans l'eau qui
s'accumulent au fond du bateau
mais la salle des machines l'abattoir
voix est gentil si et seulement des
autres ponts on va pas rester là parce
que j'ai plein de d'excréments et d'un
mélange pas de mort à déplorer
pour cette fois super boulot au principe
ça s'est bien passé
ouais très bien très bien wawrinka
sur le pont les 255 rescapés ont
désormais des vêtements secs et propres
ils sont en sécurité soulagé d'avoir été
secourues
sa maman joie et son volet va nulle part
ailleurs aucun bateau mouche quand on
est prié en chantant derrière je peux
pas être content anciens quoi quand tu
vois ce qu'on veut dire mais pas très
dur du sein dans l'enfer qu'ils ont vécu
ou la légende blind willie aflame
[Applaudissements]
au loin
leur bateau en bois et brûlé par un
navire militaire pour ne pas qu'ils
soient réutilisés par les passeurs sur
le pont arrière
elisabeth l'infirmière de médecins sans
frontières repère les cas de gale est ce
que ça te grattes la sûreté main entre
la promiscuité le manque d'eau y en a
beaucoup qui ont cette maladie si on la
gagne et on ne peut pas les traiter
mais au moins on les identifie et au
moment du des embarquements ils sont
pris en charge par les autorités
sanitaires pour les traitements
ultérieurs
elisabeth est une infirmière
expérimentée
plus d'une dizaine de missions
humanitaires à travers le monde mais
jamais sur un bateau
c'est dans ce petit hôpital de bord avec
son équipe qu'elle s'occupe de ceux qui
ont le plus souffert du voyage
[Musique]
alice l'une des soignantes donne le bain
aux enfants avec ses trois enfants
basma a fui son pays en guerre le soudan
du sud pour se convaincre soi même de
faire ce voyage en bateau avec ses
enfants c'est que vraiment ça des traces
intense vraiment quand basma est arrivé
en libye
les passeurs lui ont dit qu elle
traverserait un fleuve un fleuve nommé
méditerranée il est passeur nous ont dit
que ça prendrait quatre
et nous ont dit de ne pas avoir peur et
que la traversée se passerait bien
évidemment ça c'est pas du tout déroulée
comme prévu le bateau était en mauvais
état s'était pas un bon bateau il y
avait des morceaux de bois à l'intérieur
qui commençait à se casser et l'eau a
commencé à entrer on était tous effrayés
car l'eau montait de plus en plus on
était persuadé que l'on n'y arriverai
jamais si les gens qui nous ont sauvé
était arrivé un peu plus tard rien qu'un
tout petit peu plus tard c'était fini
pour lui
[Musique]
tous sont passés par la libye leur point
de départ pour gagner l'europe
[Musique]
mais là bas la plupart ont été arrêtés
par les forces libyennes et jetés dans
des centres de rétention en vue d'être
expulsé des centres où il reste enfermé
des semaines voire des mois
[Musique]
ces photos sont l'un des rares
témoignages de ce qu'ils endurent
tous racontent avoir subi la faim le
travail forcé et la torture
il traite les noirs comme des esclaves
il nous quitte nac dans les rues nour
groupe et peuvent nous entasser jusqu'à
4000 incessantes
ensuite ils vont appeler des gens que tu
connais pour payer une rançon
si tu donnes l'argent ils te jette
dehors mais si tu n'as pas l'argent ils
peuvent te tuer pendant ces trois mois
de détention
clément a été battu quasi
quotidiennement ça c'est un coup de
couteau avant de réussir à s'enfuir
il avait l'habitude de me frapper avec
des pierres qu'il casse avec leurs
fusils
je ne pouvais pas rester dans ce pays on
préfère mourir en mer que la barre
[Musique]
l'embarcation dans la radio ce matin là
le bateau d'une autre ong demandent du
renfort en urgence à la cua reviews à
deux heures de navigation
le golf and the row vient de retrouver
quatre embarcations hockey golf enduro
c'est très clair mais les nouvelles ne
sont pas bonnes ce jour là ludovic et
les autres bénévoles vont affronter ce
qu'ils redoutent tous depuis leur départ
de catane cette fois les sauveteurs
arrivent trop tard
[Musique]
ils rejoignent le bateau qui a trouvé
les skiffs en caoutchouc à moitié
dégonflées au large de tripoli
au fond du canot huit corps sans vie
cinq hommes et trois femmes mort
asphyxié écrasé sous le poids des 119
autres personnes qui se trouvaient à
bord prend le brancard et portland
ludovic est chargé de préparer le
brancard qui servira à remonter les
morts à bord de l'aquarius l été on est
dedans l'arrêt à 8 personnes qui ce
matin étaient en vie et qui maintenant
bas sont mortes
hélas leurs dépouilles qui sont qui
rentrent embarqués à bord il n'y a pas
de mots pour ça que la sauce prenne
le pont avant s'est transformée en
chambre funéraire improvisé
avec une simple bâche pour protéger les
corps
en libye aussi des centaines de cadavres
viennent s'échouer le long des plages
ce qu'ils ont fait naufrage avant
d'avoir pu être sauvés
ce sont les migrants eux mêmes qui
doivent ramener les corps c'était le
travail de cap ça sous le contrôle de la
police libyenne parfois je marchais de
7h à minuit juste pour récupérer les
corps des gens meurent en mer je
ramassais des bébés et des femmes
enceintes et b a peut-être deux mois de
leur accouchement est l'endroit où je
les amenais c'était une fosse commune
il devait y avoir plus de 3000 personnes
de tandil ouais bien sûr les passeurs
veulent juste votre argent alors il on
voit les gens à la mer même si le temps
est mauvais certains ne reste même pas
30 minutes en mer le bateau a des
problèmes et il meurt tous c'est trop
triste vous savez
[Musique]
il est 23h les migrants recueillis par
l'aquarius sont transférés à bord du
bateau d'une autre ong qui va les
ramener cette nuit vers l'italie
[Musique]
un transfert qui permettent à la couarde
juste continuer ses recherches
[Musique]
ce matin-là l'aquarius ne fait pas face
à un radeau mais à une menace
à 82 milles le seastar elles sont à 3000
et nous s'ils ne changent pas leurs
courses
on les verra très près aux droits devant
le seastar un navire affrété par des
militants de l'extrême droite européenne
savez-vous qui ils sont et ce qu'ils
veulent c'est pas clair en cette
inclination ni ce qu'ils veulent à bord
du seastar des membres du groupe
génération identitaire comme les
volontaires de l'aquarius ils sont tous
bénévoles comme l'aquarius ils sont
financés par des dons sur internet mais
leur objectif est bien différent ce
qu'ils veulent mettre la pression sur
les ong pour les forcer à stopper leur
aide aux migrants
tu allais d'instruction s'il commence à
nous approcher de trop près qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
on continue de patrouiller c'est tout
par radio
le seastar exige que l'aquarius quitte
la zone immédiatement on les compare
milliards on vous surveille et aucune de
coopération ne lui échappera merci pour
votre information bien compris on vous
demande de quitter la fréquentent
d'urgence 2016
la mission affichée par le seastar
défendre l'europe comme expliqué dans
cette vidéo ce qu'il se passe ici c'est
une bataille d'idées d'image c'est
l'idée d'une immigration incontrôlée de
frontières ouvertes face à l'idée de
contrôler et sécuriser nos frontières et
préserver notre identité à bord du
bateau
cinq jeunes venus d'italie d'allemagne
et même de france je viens de lyon en
france je voulais venir car je veux que
le gouvernement fasse quelque chose pour
arrêter l'immigration massive
moi je pense que toute personne je peux
avoir des pensées extrémistes racistes
penser que les gens qui sont secourus en
mer là viennent manger le pain des bons
petits européens lorsque ces personnes
là braqués viennent juste dix minutes
sur une rescue juste dix minutes tu te
retrouves pas nue brûlé par du gasoil de
l'essence piétiné par d'autres avec plus
rien avec des gars en ayant tout laisser
en ayant laissé ta famille ton chez toi
ton machin en augmenter enfants là
dedans parce que tu veux pas ce que tu
veux toucher des allocs aux des machins
il faut arrêter ça
pendant plusieurs jours le seastar
restera dans le siège de l'aquarius
multipliant les messages pour décourager
les ong
sans succès
l'aquarius poursuit sa route et sa
mission
comme ce matin là
j'ai pas d'accord le plus important il
ya de l'autre viable au fond il ya tous
à dos tous à ce type d'embarcation est
la plus utilisée par les passeurs la
plus dangereuse aussi ok on commence toi
bien donne moi ta main le caoutchouc ne
fait qu'un millimètre d'épaisseur un
millimètre pour supporter le poids de
116 personnes dans le ciel
l'avion de surveillance européen qui a
signalé l'embarcation quitte la zone
[Musique]
ces rescapés ont payé jusqu'à 1500 euros
pour embarquer sur ses radeaux de la
mort que les bénévoles préfères tu
identifié avant de repartir s'il est
trouvé par une autre organisation
ils sauront que les gens ont été
secourues et quel jour ses pairs
persée puis découpé pour le rendre
inutilisable
au cas où les passeurs voudrait s'en
servir de nouveau
vous
à bord de l'aquarius beaucoup de
rescapés arrivent blessés
jamais des antibiotiques
elisabeth les prend en charge ok c'est
parti mais ce jour là
l'infirmière aguerris de médecins sans
frontières doit faire face à un cas
grave c'est par salle c'est une blessure
par balle ce jeune ghanéen de 20 ans
s'est fait tirer dessus en pleine rue
par des libyens sans soins il risque
l'amputation
tout le monde en libye permettent quand
même où que tu ailles tu auras tout le
temps leur arme pointée sur toi s'il
voit des noix dans leur quartier ils
leur tire dessus et chétive ce jour là
ils sont arrivés et ont commencé à tirer
partout à des voix selon m
tout le monde courait et moi aussi je
courais pour sauver ma vie et c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai reçu un impact dans
ma jambe dans la jungle
elisabeth est une habituée des terrains
difficiles mais les témoignages des
migrants torturé en libye la bouleverse
on n'est pas préparé du tournoi c'est
beaucoup d'émotions c'est beaucoup
d'émotions crois qu'on avait beaucoup de
choses quand j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
en magie à travers mon travail mais
mais pas ça oui
[Musique]
il y a les blessures physiques et celles
qui ne se voit pas forcément parfois
plus profonde encore
[Musique]
toutes les femmes sont là cette salle
est réservée aux femmes et à leurs
enfants juliette la sage-femme de
l'aquarius veut les aider à sortir de
leur silence
on sait que parfois les femmes ont subi
des violences ont été utilisés peut-être
vous avez besoin de parler de ce genre
de choses dans ce foyer
les femmes peuvent enfin se sentir en
sécurité
un peu dur à l'endroit on leur demande
rien et on leur donne les choses
[Musique]
nombreuses sont les femmes qui resteront
mutique mais beaucoup demanderont à
faire un test de grossesse pour savoir
si elle porte l'enfant né d'un viol nana
elena est originaire de côte d'ivoire
elle était venue en libye pour tenter la
traversée vers l'italie mais dans la rue
des hommes armés l'ont kidnappée est ce
que tu voulais me raconter
parfois j'ai du mal à parler ils sont
venus ils ont choisi les filles elles
nous ont choisis nous on était 5
ils nous ont mis de côté il y avait une
petite fille de 11 ans ils l'ont violée
là bas et ils l'ont laissé 11 ans ils
ont couché avec les hommes aussi
même les hommes les petits garçons
ensuite des libyens l'ont séquestré avec
quatre autres femmes dans une maison les
viols étaient quotidiens c'était des
différentes personnes à chaque fois
si celui-là venayre jour demain c'était
l'autre et je le connaissais pas c'était
des personnes différentes tout le temps
à chaque fois ils crachent sur toi il
crache il te frappe
je me sentais tellement mal souvent je
leur demandais de me tuer que c'était
mieux
oui son calvaire a duré deux mois
jusqu'à ce jour où l'un des violeurs
s'assoupit en laissant la clé accessible
na na iza ouvre la porte et s'enfuit
c'est courageux nous balade tout ce
qu'on a vécu tu sais ça me libère on
mène allée par allée mais l'entente de
ses propres oreilles la personne qu'il a
vécu c'est autre chose c'est évident où
non c'est pas facile on a envie de mai
mais bon on est là pour faire faire face
aux gens qui souffrent change tout la
perception du problème des migrants on
les considère comme un groupe de
personnes qu'on ne veut pas avoir en
europe pour pour des raisons à plus ou
moins justifiées mais en tout cas quand
on entend individuellement ce genre du
store on n'avait qu'une envie c'est de
les sortir de là libye ne pas qu'ils y
restent et je pense que n'importe qui en
tant que ça peut pas se dire oui on vous
renvoie en libye la vie est belle là bas
vous allez bien vous amuser vous allez
avoir du travail
c'est pas du tout ce qui s'y passe quoi
[Musique]
vous
dernière nuit en mer pour les rescapés
[Musique]
il est temps de mettre le cap sur
pozzato le port italien où ils seront
débarqués à votre arrivée il y aura
beaucoup de gens pour vous prendre en
charge
c'est normal ne paniquez pas vous devez
expliquer pourquoi le pays dont vous
venez était dangereux côté
cette demande d'asile peut prendre
jusqu'à un an
et en attendant vous vivrez dans des
centres avec d'autres personnes dans le
même cas que né
les bénévoles le savent pour les
migrants italie sera le début d'une
nouvelle épreuve
60% d'entre eux ne sont pas éligibles au
droit d'asile accordées en priorité à
ceux qui fuient les conflits ou une
dictature
la plupart seront donc expulsables
certains ce pas trop d'illusions
demandeurs d'asile économique durant
leur demande d'en rajouter
voilà mais on est content comment ils
sont devenus sommes pas morts en libye
ou en mer
[Musique]
c'est le moment qu'ils attendent depuis
si longtemps ils ont parcouru des
milliers de kilomètres et risquer leur
vie pour arriver ici en europe
une émotion pour eux mais aussi pour les
humanitaires qui les ont sauvés rêver
gallagher
mbaye on a près les connaître une à une
mon espoir le meilleur pour elle et elle
ont beaucoup de rêves en tête alain bac
à sable où suis je
merci d'avoir mon ami [ __ ] ceci étant
dit préférer le meilleur pour voir la
première fois que ça va vite c'est
intense et des visages d'un mot que je
voudrais par un certain que je n'ai
jamais alors qu'ils font leurs premiers
pas sur le sol italien l'aquarius repart
déjà en mission bénévole et qui va j'ai
soignants ensemble ils ont sorti des
limbes de la méditerranée seize mille
migrants l'an passé ces naufragés au
rêve si simple
celui d'une vie meilleure
[Musique]
il